Don't pick up on my parents right
now.
Oh, don't thank me.
Next month, I'll draw a speech.
You're fucking hilarious.
You crack me up.
I would love to be fucking 5
'6".
Jesus Christ, it would be so sweet
to be 5 '6".
I'm working on it.
He did.
I'm fucking against it.
Shut your fucking mouth.
You're the fucking fourth guy in the
rack.
Shut up.
Honestly, you're not you guys aren't gonna
So check your
Back to fifth in the rack and
sit your fucking ass in your car
and do back home and do nothing
You listen long officer come cops are
here.
Goodbye.
That's why I'm at cops are here
I'm not scared.
No, I'm not.
I'm not trying to be scared.
Yo, we're not scared of you.
That's a fact.
But you guys are being fucking actually
aggressive and it's annoying.
Don't be aggressive to me.
Please, we're trying to get this figured
out.
That little, that little, that little push.
Oh my god, I'm so tough.
Stupid fight that happened to nothing.
I'm so tough.
Bring us home.
I have a dog that I suck.
How about you guys be cool cops?
I lick my dog's cunt.
Bring us home.
I lick my dog's cunt every night
at home.
Oh my god.
Shut the fuck up.
See, he thinks I...
I didn't drive.
I'm in no trouble.
I'm fine.
Everybody, every single one of these cocksuckers
can get on their knees and suck
on my dick.
They're sitting here like they're important, but
they need to go.
Nah, he's not important.
He's like fucking...
He might be.
You guys should have walked away.
He's 22 years old.
Are we home?
Nick, Nick, Nick.
Bye.
Well, you gotta get, hang on one
second, you gotta get your ticket.